in this video i want to give you a
general idea of what a bond is and why a
company might even issue them in the
first place and just at a very high
level a bond is essentially a way for
someone to participate in lending to a
company so you're a partial lender
partial
lender
to a company and just to make that more
concrete let's imagine some type of
company that has 10 million dollars in
assets
so these are its assets right there
and it has 10
million dollars in assets and let's say
just for the sake of simplicity it has
no liabilities so all of that value all
that 10 million dollars is what is owned
by the owners or by the equity the
owner's equity so this is 10 million
dollars
10 million dollars in equity
and if we had
let's say a million shares i'll write it
down if we have a million shares
and if we believe this 10 million dollar
number that implies that each share is
worth 10 dollars per share
now let's say this company is doing
really well and it wants to expand it
wants to increase its assets by five
million dollars so it can go out and buy
a five million dollar factory so it
wants
let me draw it right here it wants
another five million dollars in assets
that it needs to build that factor or
essentially a five million dollar
factory
and the question is how does it finance
it
well one way is that they could just
issue more equity if they're able to get
a price of ten dollars per share they
could issue another five hundred
thousand shares 500 000 shares
at
per share
and then that would essentially it
produce 5 million dollars so this is
scenario one they issue five hundred
thousand shares at ten dollars a share
they now have one point five million
shares
but these new owners gave them
collectively five million dollars
so this the equity would grow by 5
million we now have 1.5 million shares
so this would now be 1.5 million shares
not 1 million and that new money from
these new shareholders would go into the
asset side and then we would use that to
actually buy the factory
what i just described is essentially
issuing equity or financing via equity
financing
via
equity or by issuing stock
now the other way to do it is to borrow
the money to borrow the money so let me
redraw
this company i'll leave this up here
just so we can compare the two so once
again we have 10 million dollars of
assets
that's our 10 million dollars of assets
we have 10 million dollars of equity to
start off with
10 million dollars of equity
and instead of issuing stock to get the
five million dollars we're going to
borrow the money
so we could
we're essentially issuing debt
so we issue we essentially we could go
to a bank and say hey bank can i borrow
5 million so we would have a 5 million
in liability it would be debt 5 million
dollars of debt and the bank would give
us 5 million dollars of cash that we can
then go use to buy our factory so in
either situation in either situation the
asset side of our balance sheet looks
identical or the assets of the company
are identical we had our 10 million
assets and now we have a factory but in
this first situation i increased i was
able to raise that money by increasing
the number of shareholders by increasing
the number of people that i have to
split the profits of these of this of
this company with in this situation i
was able to raise the money by borrowing
it so these the people that i'm
borrowing this money from the people
that i'm borrowing this money this is
borrowed money
borrowed money they don't get a cut of
the profits of this company what they do
is they get paid interest on their money
that they're lending to us before these
guys get any profits at all in fact that
interest is considered an expense so
these guys
get
interest
get interest and even if this company
does super super well and becomes very
very profitable these guys only get
their interest likewise if the company
does really bad and these guys suffer as
long as the company doesn't go bankrupt
these guys are still going to get their
interest so they're going to be a lot
safer
than well they don't get as much of the
reward as the new equity holders would
they also don't get as much of the risk
now this is just straight up debt and
you could just get this from any bank if
they were willing to if they said oh you
know you're a good safe company we're
willing to lend you five million dollars
but let's say that no bank
wants to individually take on that risk
so you say hey why don't instead of
borrowing five million dollars from one
entity why don't i buy borrow it from 5
000 entities so what i can do instead
instead of borrowing it from one entity
i could issue these certificates i could
issue bonds
and that's the topic of this video so i
issue these certificates
they have a face value of one thousand
dollars
one thousand dollars this is my face
value
face value or sometimes you'll hear the
the notion of par value
of par value and i'll say what interest
i'm going to pay on it so let's say i i
say it has a 10
annual coupon
and it's actually called even though
this is the interest i'm essentially
going to pay a hundred dollars a year
it's called a coupon because when they
when bonds were first issued they would
actually throw these little coupons on
the bond itself and the owner of the
certificate could rip off or cut off one
of these coupons and then go to the
person borrowing or the entity borrowing
the money and get their actual interest
payment so that's why it's actually
called coupons but they don't actually
attach those coupons anymore and it has
some maturity date the date that not
only will i pay your interest back but
i'll pay the entire principal the entire
face value so let's say the maturity
maturity is in two years
is in two years so in this situation in
order to raise five million dollars i'm
going to have to issue 5 thousand of
these because five thousand times one
thousand is five million so times
five
thousand so if you wanted to lend a
thousand dollars to this company so that
they could expand and if you think 10
percent is a good interest rate and it's
a safe company you would essentially buy
one of these bonds maybe you buy it for
1 000 and when you buy that bond for 1
you are essentially lending this company
that one thousand dollars and if you did
that five thousand times or if that
happened five thousand times amongst a
bunch of different people this company
would be able to raise its five million
dollars
now just to be clear how the actual
payments work
the coupons tend to get paid
semi-annually so let me draw a little
timeline here
and this tends to be the case in the us
and western europe if this is today
this is today this is in six months
this is in 12 months or one year
this is in 18 months
and this is in 24 months and i'm only
going up to 24 months because i said
this bond matures in 24 months so what
is this if you own if you hold this bond
this certificate what do you get
well it's going to pay you 10
annually so 100 a year
per year
but they actually pay the coupon semi
annually so you get a hundred dollars a
year but you get half of it every six
months so you're gonna get fifty dollars
after six months you're gonna get fifty
dollars after twelve months or after
another six months you're gonna get
another fifty dollars here you're gonna
get a final fifty dollars there and
they're also going to have to pay you
back the original amount of the loan
they're also gonna have to pay you the a
thousand dollars so that last payment is
going to be the coupon of 50 plus the
thousand dollars and so you will have
essentially been getting this 10
annual interest now when the company
does this they'll probably have to issue
some type of new bond because all of a
sudden they have to pay all of these
people this huge lump sum of money if
they haven't been able to earn it from
the factories yet and we could talk
about that in a future video